alice good morning to you yesterday i  was doing some work at home  and i'm still trying to wrap my brain  around the fact that it's 20 21 so i  kept filling out all these things online  i kept putting in 2020 and it would  send me an alert saying that i got it  all wrong so  my caliber we're only five days in i  gotta recalibrate i know i feel like we  just got the hang of writing 2020  although none of us wanted to write it  so  yeah that's always a hard a hard part of  um of the new year but sherry  um i think we're all just happy to be  done with 2020 yeah i think so yeah did  you see all the memes about you know  like  pushing 20 20 out and just i i got a ton  of them through the new year holiday so  i'm sure they're still coming in uh 2020  was so easy to write though 2021 takes a  little  extra effort now to think about it